[Music]  my mother's coach man Edison in my  cousin I like the tail out there you yes  excuse me  I love Aladdin I love you I don't hear  you okay good  I love good what I said why are you  talking like wash shut up  my boyfriend Aladdin is not Aladdin  you're just jealous that you can't get  any there's a pool here that's not a  genie  my carpet you're standing on it what all  right let's go  close your eyes oh yeah  [Music]  [Applause]  hey Dean are you a coffee  yeah grappa ray Apollo sorry did you say  royal yes can I go there no rock back  what's that  ah oh my god where's my bag Oh  oh my god yeah they gave it to play  sunglasses I'm not my son walking there  on your head  Oh mad my phone my god I can't be  without me pizza in your hand in my hand  sorry I was such a long dry shaven gum  yeah I think I might have a case after  lunch in London in space war  [Music]